so if you're a Merced and you smelled  smoke the other day it was my grandma's  these [ __ ] Tweakers that are like two  acres out they're tweaking we know them  Tweakers they've been Tweakers as my dad  was a little kid their kids are Tweakers  and their kids are Tweakers your  children's children's children I just  watched the book the other day and your  children's children will be hooked on  meth  and their children's children  hooked  oh  [ __ ]  you [ __ ] Captain Hook Captain  Hook and he's just like this  or the pookie  oh yes first Freddy Krueger yeah first  Freddy now it's Captain Hook  we're on to something here okay sorry  we're onto something back to this  horribleness  [Music]